es ist april und wir können so viele
Gemüsepflanzen Aussehen sowohl hier im
Haus in der Anzucht als auch dann
draußen im Garten da gehen wir gleich
auch noch hin wie z.B die Wassermelone
und die Zucchini die ganzen Gurken das
machen wir gleich weil dafür brauchen
wir größeren und fangen erstmal mit
denen an die hier in diese Töpfchen
gehören also legen wir los mit dem
Wirsing das habe ich wieder ein Wurzel
wirksam
dass ich aufreißen muss obwohl ich es
nicht aufreißen will kann das auch so
ganz vorsichtig hier oben auftrennen für
alle die sich mitbekommen haben wir
haben neue Dings unser eigenes Saatgut
rausgebracht ich bin so ein großer Fan
von den Tütchen sich mit denen echt
zimperlich bin so sieht es doch viel
schöner aus als aufgerissen kann man
jetzt aussehen und viele denken
wahrscheinlich Wirsing ist doch ein
richtiges Wintergemüse warum sollte man
das jetzt aussehen wo noch nicht mal der
Sommer richtig zu spüren ist aber wer im
Winter große Pflanzen ernten möchte
natürlich den Pflanzen viel Zeit geben
groß zu werden Wirsing braucht dafür
schon seine paar Monate bevor es dann
richtig kalt wird und die Pflanzen
sowieso nicht weiter wachsen das ist die
Sorte paradiesler und dann denke ich die
mit Erde zu dann kommt meine Ballbrause
ins Spiel es ist so eine sanfte Dusche
für die Samenkörnchen dass die nicht
überall hin verschlimmt werden wir
machen weiter mit dem Brokkoli Brokkoli
kann man jetzt auch aussehen die erntet
man noch bevor es richtig tiefer Winter
ist also die sind schon auch ein
bisschen Frost hat man kann sich noch
ein bisschen den Herbst hinein aber der
ist vorher Ernte Ralf den sehe ich ganz
genauso aus die sind in der gleichen
Pflanzenfamilie steht auch immer auf den
Samen Tütchen mit drauf wie tief die
gesät werden welchen Abstand die später
brauchen die Brokkoli sollte die ich
jetzt aussehen heißt kalinaro ich sage
euch immer die Sorten mit dazu weil es
gibt so viele unterschiedliche
Gemüsesorten und manche haben sich
einfach mehr bewährt natürlich könnt ihr
auch andere Sachen nehmen ich finde das
immer schön wenn man von anderen Leuten
Tipps bekommt die sich in einem anderen
Garten schon richtig bewährt haben das
übrigens der Kohlrabi den ich jetzt
aussehe eine lilafarbene Sorte die heißt
Azure Star ich verteile die Samen immer
so im Töpfchen das hier ist ein bisschen
Platz für sich hat vielleicht fragen
sich manche warum ich manche Gemüse
immer wieder aussehe das liegt daran
dass wenn man regelmäßig aushält dass
man dann natürlich auch regelmäßig
erntet wenn man jetzt nur einmal im
Februar sein Kohlrabi sät dann sind die
ja alle ungefähr gleichzeitig erntereif
und dann wird man einmal überschwemmt
mit der ganzen Menge Kohlrabi die man
aber gar nicht so schnell verarbeiten
kann und deswegen sehe ich einfach
kleinere Sätze immer wieder rund ums
Jahr aus um rund ums Jahr ernten zu
können jetzt könnten wir auch den
Winterlauf sehen wenn ihr jetzt noch
Aussehen wollt dann würde ich euch die
Sorte blau grüner Winter empfehlen jetzt
den Winter nach außen damit man dann im
Winter immer noch ganz viel kann und das
ist so ein schönes Gefühl man muss nur
rechtzeitig dran denken und deswegen ist
mein Gold kennt ihr jetzt auch aussehen
das ist die Sorte volljährige ansonsten
mag ich auch sehr gerne in den Sorten
Mix der heißt rain da sind noch andere
Farben mit dabei den sehe ich jetzt auch
nicht aus weil ich habe genug Mangold
und bei mangold ist das so dass man den
ja auch über einen langen Zeitraum
beenden kann also einen Kohlrabi
schneidet man ab und die Pflanze ja ist
fertig sind zu sagen und an der Stelle
kann man dann einfach eine neue Pflanze
anbauen und was würde kein zweiter
Kohlrabi aus der Wurzel entstehen beim
mangold ist das so dass man einzelne
Steine von außen ernten kann und das
Herz der Pflanze in Tag lassen kann und
da wachsen dann jede Menge neue Stangen
raus so dass man immer wieder weiter
enden kann deswegen muss man Mangold z.B
nicht so oft nachsehen wie eine Kohlrabi
als nächstes haben wir den Salat da habe
ich jetzt die Seite Summertime wenn den
Salat frostfest ist und man den über den
Winter anbauen kann wie zum Beispiel
meine heißgeliebten dann heißt das
normalerweise dass er ziemlich schnell
in die Blüte geht weil er eben auch ganz
andere Bedingungen gezüchtet wurde der
hier ist er für den Sommer geeignet und
geht im Sommer nicht so schnell in die
Blüte deswegen ist es auch wichtig dass
man über das Jahr verteilt bei den
allermeisten Gemüsepflanzen die
regelmäßig aussät unterschiedliche
Sorten verwendet für die
unterschiedlichen Jahreszeiten hier habe
ich jetzt größere Töpfchen wir haben die
Zucchini
Zucchini ist schon Kandidat die sätt ihr
in einzelne Töpfchen und normalerweise
braucht man nicht mehr als maximal zwei
Zucchini Pflanzen für eine normale große
Familie ich sehe jetzt drei aus damit
wir auf der sicheren Seite sind und auf
jeden Fall genug zu Teenie bekommen ich
sage das nur aus Witz weil der Reif vom
Selbstversorger kann alles immer sagt
also Zucchini werden wir drei aus und
die kommen in einzelne Töpfchen bei alle
Gemüsepflanzen die jetzt noch übrig sind
hier in meiner Hand wollen in große
Töpfe gesät werden und nicht später
pikiert und umgepflanzt werden das sind
die ganzen Kürbisgewächse die sind da so
ein bisschen eigen
und es ist auf jeden Fall von Vorteil
wenn man ein bisschen mehr aushält als
man später braucht einfach weil es immer
Ausfälle gibt weil man sich dann die
stärksten Pflänzchen aussuchen kann und
so landen am Ende einfach die
kräftigsten gemüsepflänzchen im Bild und
man hat auf jeden Fall genug Pflanzen
also als nächstes kommt die Wassermelone
und ich weiß gar nicht warum ich das
Tütchen jetzt aufreiße weil ich will die
eigentlich gar nicht anbauen ich wollte
euch nur zeigen dass das möglich ist
wenn er das ausprobieren wollt die Sorte
die ich am ehesten empfehlen kann ist
sugar Baby sieht so aus wenn man Glück
hat bei mir hat es noch nie geklappt
dass ich selbst im Gewächshaus in
Deutschland richtig leckere Wassermelone
angebaut habe die sind klein die sind
hell rosa wenn überhaupt und schmecken
nicht besonders süß zumindest bei mir
und ich habe das bestimmt schon drei
Jahre ausprobiert aber wenn ihr wollt
probiert aus es gibt ja auch noch andere
Melonen wie Honigmelonen und so weiter
die könnt ihr auch jetzt alle im Haus im
Töpfchen aussehen
dann haben wir hier die Tanja es ist
eine meiner liebsten Freilandgurken ich
habe noch eine andere Lieblingssorte die
heißt marketmore 76 es gibt
Freilandgurken und Gewächshaus Gurken
und ich baue immer beides an obwohl ich
genug Platz um Gewächshaus hätte und nur
da unten zu haben ich habe das Gefühl im
Gewächshaus wenn man da einmal eine
fiese Krankheit oder Schädlinge drin hat
dann bleiben die da auch jetzt einfach
sehr schnell dass dann alle Pflanzen
befallen sind ich hatte schon mal ein
Jahr ich glaube das war sogar letztes
Jahr ein ziemlicher Totalausfall ab
August bei meinen Gurken und das ist
natürlich super schade deswegen war ich
sehr froh dass ich draußen im Freiland
auch noch Gurken hatte was bei mir auf
jeden Fall nicht fehlen darf sind
Einlegegurken ich bin ein riesen Fan vom
einkochen und vom fermentieren allgemein
vom haltbar machen ich Dürre super viel
ich friere neuerdings auch sehr viel ein
und Liebe ist einfach im Sommer genug
haltbar zu machen um im Winter immer
noch richtig vielfältig aus den eigenen
Garten essen zu können ist einfach so
ein gutes Gefühl mit ihren eigenen
kleinen Wintervorrat in den Winter zu
gehen deswegen sehe ich auch
Einlegegurken aus ihr seht das ne die
sehen ein bisschen anders aus als
normale Gurken die sind einfach viel
kleiner die haben auch so ein bisschen
so Stacheln das ist eine andere Sorte
als wenn man ganz normale Gewächshaus
Gurken oder so Schlangengurken angebaut
oder auch zu Snack wollen meine
Lieblingssorte sind die Vorgebirge
tragen man weiß dass man deine
Lieblingssorte hat wenn man nur noch ein
Kürzel verwendet um seine Pflänzchen zu
beschäftigen
das sind jetzt die evgt aber natürlich
will ich auch Gurken im Gewächshaus
anbauen einfach wenn man da noch mal
dünnschaligere
schlangengurkenartige Sorten anbauen
kann die so ein bisschen mehr sind wie
die sollten die man aus dem Supermarkt
kennt oder eigentlich genauso viel
leckerer und eigentlich ist meine
Lieblingssorte die Helena das ist eine
Patino Karte Sorte die nur weibliche
Blüten bildet und sehr wenig Kerne hat
das bedeutet aber auch dass man im
gleichen Gewächshaus keine andere Sorte
anbauen können die eventuell auch
mündlicher Blüten bildet und das
schränkt mich so ein bisschen ein im
rumprobieren und dieses Jahr möchte ich
auch andere Sorten ausprobieren deswegen
baue ich auch die Sorte
cleofan habt ihr noch Tipps für
gurkensorten oder allgemein sollten
Tipps für irgendwelche Gemüsepflanzen
ich finde das immer sehr interessant ich
habe auch schon viele Tomatensorten
ausprobiert weil ihr die in den
Kommentaren empfohlen hat und ich glaube
das andere Leute auch immer gerne in den
Kommentaren unterwegs sind und danach
Tipps suchen das ist so schön an unserer
Wurzelwerk Community das ja auch Tipps
gibt in den Kommentaren und das ist auch
ein großes Geschenk irgendwie so eine
tolle Community zu haben was ihr jetzt
auch noch sehen könnt wäre die
mexikanische Minigurke die Macht so ganz
ganz kleine Minigolfen die ziemlich
lecker schmecken also so salzig sind die
ein bisschen und frisch was ihr jetzt
auch sehen könnt sind Kürbisse das ist
auch das was ich dieses Jahr nicht mache
mit einem weinenden Augen zwei weinenden
Augen weil das einfach mit dem Umzug
nicht klappt aber jetzt gehen wir
erstmal nach draußen in meinen alten
Gärten und dann zeige ich euch welche
Gemüse erst nach draußen sehen könnt
direkt ins Beet und welche
gemüsepflänzchen ihr jetzt auch nach
draußen Pflanzen könnt also bis gleich
und nach draußen ins Beet könnt ihr
jetzt auch schon jede Menge
Gemüsepflanzen Aussehen ich mache das
oft sogar lieber als im Haus weil die
Pflanzen die man direkt sieht oft
kräftiger werden weil die nicht so oft
umgetopft werden und gleich eine richtig
schöne lange Wurzel entwickeln können so
dass sie dann auch resistent dagegen
Trockenheit sind also wenn ihr die Wahl
habt dann seid lieber direkt ins Bett
z.B den Asia Salat den könnt ihr jetzt
sehen dass es einen leckeren asiatischer
Salat stell ich euch ja oft in meinen
Videos vor dicke Bohnen könnt ihr jetzt
auch sehen das macht immer richtig Spaß
weil die Samen können so richtig groß
sind und man da endlich mal was in der
Hand hat das ist viel schöner als zum
Beispiel Karotten auszusehen das geht
aber jetzt auch die würde ich niemals
heraus vorziehen weil das bei einem
Wurzelgemüse gar keinen Sinn ergibt die
also immer direkt ins Beet Mangold könnt
ihr es auch nach draußen Aussehen ich
bekomme oft die Frage gestellt wie man
Mangold am Ende zubereitet und ich nehme
am liebsten die Blätter genauso wie
Spinat man kann die ihn auch roh essen
im Salat aber meistens mache ich eine
Lasagne draus so wie in der Spinat
Lasagne oder zu kartoffelpreise und
mangold-gemüse und die Stangen kann man
einfach in kleine Stücke schneiden ich
fermentiere die auch super gerne alle
die in meinem Obst und Gemüse haltbar
machen Kurs dabei sind wissen das das
richtig viel Spaß macht wenn man den
einfach in Flaschen stopft und
fermentiert eine ganz eigene Methode
sonst kann man die Stange auch einfach
mit in der Gemüsepfanne schnippeln da ja
hat man ganz viele Möglichkeiten ihr
könnt jetzt Rettich aussehen das ist
auch so ein richtige Link sicheres
Gemüse also wenn euch Rettich schmeckt
oder ihr vielleicht auch mal den Kimchi
machen wollt das hätte ich auch richtig
toll dann macht das der wächst wie
Unkraut zumindest bei mir RO Rakete
könnt ihr jetzt aussehen und ein anderes
Gemüse das auch rot ist die milde die
macht richtig Spaß im Garten weil die so
knallrot ist die ist wunderschön und
auch wenn man dann den Salat Teller hat
wo einfach so ein paar Farbtupfer drin
sind ist das einfach ne richtig schöne
Sache Rucola könnt ihr jetzt aussehen
und Salat bei Salat ist es im Freiland
immer ein bisschen schwierig also wenn
Regen angekündigt ist dann ist es
perfekt um Salat auszusehen weil man die
Samen nur oben auf den Boden aufstreuse
das ist eine Lichtkeimer den darf man so
höchstens einen Millimeter dick mit Erde
bedecken und an heißen Tagen oder
trockenen Tagen kann das natürlich ganz
schnell austrocknen deswegen ziehe ich
den meistens trotzdem im Haus vor
Sauerampfer könnt ihr jetzt aussehen
oder auch Schnitt Knoblauch das ist eine
mehrjähriges Zwiebelgewächs was nach
Knoblauch schmeckt mein Ende da wie bei
Schnittlauch auch die Grünen
oberirdischen Teile winterhecken
Zwiebeln könnt ihr jetzt auch sehen die
sind auch mehrjährig das heißt ihr habt
quasi einen unendlichen supply an
linkszwiebeln das ist ein richtig coole
Sache
Schwarzwurzeln habe ich persönlich noch
nie angebaut aber ja theoretisch kennt
ihr die jetzt aussehen ich habe immer
ein bisschen Respekt davor wie das ist
wenn man die dann ausbuddeln muss und
Spinat könnt ihr jetzt sehen ihr könnt
jetzt Steckrüben säen und Zwiebeln könnt
ihr es auch direkt in Speed sein genauso
wie Erbsen und Zuckererbsen erbsen sind
ja mein heimliches Lieblingsgemüse weil
die so süß schmecken wenn man die
einfach so vom Strauch aber vielleicht
wollt ihr es euch ja auch leicht machen
und habt euch Jungpflanzen gekauft oder
wollt auf dem Wochenmarkt ein paar
Pflänzchen mitnehmen habt Pflänzchen im
Haus vorgezogen die jetzt langsam groß
werden und fragt euch welche davon jetzt
schon ins Bett können das sind zum
Beispiel der Blumenkohl und der Brokkoli
allgemein die ganzen Kohlgemüse z.B auch
der Weißkohl und der Rotkohl den könnt
ihr jetzt pflanzen achtet beim Aussehen
und beim rausfinden natürlich immer aufs
Wetter also wenn jetzt erstmal zwei
Wochen lang Frost angekündigt ist dann
braucht ihr jetzt wieder sehen noch
irgendwas raus Pflanzen da also immer
einen Auge drauf haben und ich würde
euch auch empfehlen dass wenn die
Temperaturen unter 5 Grad fallen dass
ihr die Pflänzchen dann in einen
Winterschutz fließt einmummelt das kann
man einfach drüber legen mit Steinen
beschweren und allein dieses Vlies macht
schon den Temperaturunterschied von bis
zu 5 Grad aus also das ist eine richtig
gute Sache man kann jetzt noch Knoblauch
stecken dafür brecht ihr einfach die
zehn auseinander und steckt die dann mit
dem spitzen Ende nach oben in den Boden
ich habe meinen Knoblauch schon im
Herbst gepflanzt weil die Knollen dann
einfach ein bisschen dicker werden bis
zur Ernte hat ein bisschen Vorsprung
aber was ich gesehen habe ist dass ich
bei der letzten Ernte in den parkknollen
im Boden vergessen habe und die treiben
jetzt aus wenn ihr schon mal Knoblauch
angebaut habt dann kennt ihr das
bestimmt die könnte jetzt einfach aus
dem Boden raushebeln so dass ihr die
Wurzeln nicht allzu sehr verletzt und
dann vereinseln ich hatte z.B zwischen
meinen anderen Knoblauch Pflanzen noch
ein paar Lücken weil meine Enten den
Knoblauch im Frühling einmal komplett
ruiniert hat und mit den Wild
aufgegangenen vergessenen Knoblauch
Pflänzchen habe ich jetzt einfach die
Lücken gestopft also wenn ihr die
vereinzeltet dann kann aus jeder kleinen
Pflanze noch eine schöne große Knolle
werden wo wir gerade bei Knollen sind
ihr könnt jetzt auch Kartoffeln pflanzen
da achtet bitte auch aufs Wetter man
kann Kartoffeln auch noch im Mai liegen
also es ist jetzt überhaupt nicht eilig
wenn ich jetzt zu früh Kartoffeln
Pflanze dann unter den fließt und auch
nur die Frühkartoffeln die ich eben auch
sehr früh im Jahr ernten möchte und noch
eine Knolle der Knollensellerie den
könnte jetzt auch nach draußen Pflanzen
und noch eine Knolle der Kohlrabi der
geht jetzt auch ich glaube mehr Knollen
habe ich nicht in petto außer vielleicht
die Zwiebeln die sind auch ein bisschen
knollenförmig da könnt ihr jetzt sowohl
vorgezogene Pflänzchen nach draußen
setzen ich habe z.B hier so ein paar
Lauchzwiebeln das geht aber auch schon
mit Gemüsezwiebeln oder ihr holt euch
Steckzwiebeln und steckt die die steckt
man auch immer so dass die Spitze Seite
nach oben zeigt sonst können die nicht
wachsen also das ist wichtig dass man
darauf achtet eng mit der Zwiebel
verwandt ist der Lauch den könnt ihr
jetzt auch nach draußen Pflanzen dann
könnt ihr jetzt Schalotten nach draußen
Pflanzen genauso wie die Zwiebeln auch
entweder vorgezogene Pflänzchen oder
kleine steckschalotten er kennt auch den
Stangensellerie jetzt nach draußen
Pflanzen den Weißkohl den Wirsing und
Salat könnt ihr jetzt auch nach draußen
Pflanzen und wenn ihr das Problem habt
dass eure jungen Pflänzchen die ihr
jetzt nach draußen Pflanzen wollt
irgendwie so lang gezogen und
schwächlich sind und auch umkippen dann
schaut mal hier vorbei die habe ich euch
nämlich ein Video verlinkt wo ich euch
zeige was schief gelaufen ist und wie
eure Pflänzchen in Zukunft richtig schön
kräftig und gedrungen werden also viel
spaß damit geht raus macht die Welt ein
bisschen grüner und ist ganz bald
tschüss